hi i'm alvin welcome back to tasty's
making it big today i'm gonna be making
a giant popeyes chicken sandwich because
i've actually never had the real one
until last week and i just wanted to see
what the hype was about i thought it was
pretty good the first time i had it so
thought it would be fun to make a giant
fried chicken sandwich and not only a
giant fried chicken sandwich but the
popeye's one so enough talk let's get
going
so we are first gonna get started with
the big bun i have yeast some warm milk
and we have to add in a little bit of
sugar for the east to eat a sprinkling
of flour mix
you go hang out over there thank you
dude now we have
i don't know if you guys remember from
the previous seasons of making it big we
had a stand mixer named todd uh
unfortunately todd couldn't make it we
put him through a little too much work
and he is now in the the kitchenaid
scrap yard so we have a new one
uh i will christen it with a new name
this mixer's name shall be known as
bertha from here on out and we're gonna
start making the dough this is bertha's
first maiden voyage so we're gonna put
in a lot of flour
stop smelling
some sugar
salt just gonna give it a little mix i
like that we have the clear bowl so that
you guys can see what's going on in goes
the eggs
that's the sound eggs make
oh it's a beat
yeah
there we
go whoa whoa whoa bertha calm down now i
locked you in the back why are you are
you still going up it's okay it's gonna
like you know suppress bertha while uh
while she mixes this dough all right
let's see how this yeast oh it grow up a
little bit slowly going in hey yo calm
down bertha simmer down now better not
spray any of that up at me i'm gonna be
mad
we're gonna speed this up a little bit
so it uh may be a good time to scrape
down the sides
[Music]
that is some gluten hello good job
bertha you're killing it back in you go
[ __ ] now we have the butter that you're
gonna add in little by little honestly i
could probably watch this all day it's
like watching a gif but instead of
looping it's free because it keeps going
on its own that's nice i like free
things all the dough is getting nice and
glossy bertha's heating up now that all
the butter is in this needs to go at
speed three for about five minutes and
you know you know we all had the milo
test in pe well stand mixers have the
brioche test because i gotta do this for
five minutes so keep up the good work
so uh bertha is actually getting quite
hot i can almost cook an egg on this
thing and well you know you look at this
this is a it's a tornado bertha's got
that
stupid thick brioche going on look at
that oh my god
here we go
that's pretty
that's how you know it's ready all this
dough is stuck to the hook look at that
oh my god that's beautiful good job
bertha you killed it you go rest over
there
good job
look at this
you just
that's some crazy cool gluten look at
that all right some flour it's like
liquid dough
you guys ever play with like slime
or the thing you make in school with
like the cornstarch this is what it's
like all right we're gonna get you in
here
nice okay
this guy's in here gotta let this proof
and we'll be right back
all right so our little brioche baby has
grown up quite a bit and we're gonna
punch our baby in the face
ow all right gotta get this guy out oh
that's awesome it's like honeycomb gotta
get this into a nice ball because he's
sticky now i know why they call it a bed
scraper this is a quite troublesome baby
where's it gonna have to
yolo this one
please don't treat your kids like that
if you're a professional baker or work
in the industry feel free to roast how
bad i did that but on this show we do
what we can so this is gonna proof and
then we're gonna put in the oven
so we have here two large not chicken
because turkey made a lot more sense we
have two
very large turkey breasts it also has
the beautiful delicious skin on it which
i think is great
so even though this is a popeye's
chicken sandwich i won't tell if you
don't but this is a turkey sandwich all
right i'm gonna go in here get that nice
butterfly going when you're butterflying
something like this you gotta check your
work it's like in school when you do the
math problems
all right that's one we're gonna do one
we're gonna do two check your work
all right i skewer this together get in
like that then you gotta go down then we
go up
there we go let's check if we can lift
it and if it holds together
this is one of the two because a
popeye's chicken sandwich has a good
amount of meat and i don't like to skimp
on meat when it comes to these sorts of
dishes so i'm gonna make another one of
these and we will be right back
so we are gonna bread our beautiful
turkey breast and in order to do that we
gotta make a seasoned flour mixture to
get as much flavor in there as possible
i'm not sure if this is the exact same
recipe that popeyes uses because
you know then i could run them out of
business so we got seasoning got some
salt flour some pepper paprika ooh it
smells nice oh it's spicy cayenne
paprika just gonna give that a whisk i'm
gonna go in here we are using large cake
pans as our breading stations this is
making it big and where the
unconventional is conventional shout out
to home depot evenly mixed no big lumps
and this is buttermilk for the chicken
you gotta season your chicken heavily
make sure it tastes good got the salt
some nice pepper
a large piece of meat needs a lot of
seasoning
you know when chicken or turkey is
seasoned when it stops looking like its
original form into the flower or the
largest breading situation i've ever
done
it's like making the zen garden the
buttermilk
nice
good coat back in the flower
some nice crackles going on
all right in here yeah this is it's
gonna be a nicely breaded piece of
chicken i mean turkey i mean chicken
whoa this is one big chicken turkey i
mean chicken
all right this is my chicken sandwich
and that's one that was fun i'm gonna do
another one and we're gonna go fry this
thing
oh happy halloween
popeye's chicken sandwich does come with
a sauce and we're gonna make a spicy
mayo which is one of the most
complicated recipes there is because you
gotta put mayo
and spicy we got hot sauce contrary to
my chinese roots i'm not a big spice
tolerant person so i'm gonna
yeah that's spicy i'm just only gonna do
a little bit nobody tell especially my
mom she would disown me yeah i don't
know i think i would like to say that my
negative affinity towards spice is a
it's a good defense evolutionary
mechanism not that i just can't eat at
restaurants and i'm a wuss when i eat a
pepper or hot cheeto i like to tell
myself that it's a good it's a good
thing it's gonna help me in the long run
spicy mayo very easy you put mayo and
you put spicy together and you have
spicy mayo i wanna go bake the bun now
okay so this little guy's been
proofing for quite a while
i gotta put the baby in the oven that's
a word no one should ever say and you go
dude
nice and big
okay baby's in the oven we're gonna fry
some chicken
the heat is radiating
i'm about to do something very dangerous
please do not do this at home we have
very very hot oil one breaded chicken
turkey chicken patty that i made earlier
in a dream and we're gonna fry this but
please do not ever do this because we
have trained professionals on set
all right here we go don't do this at
home ever
that is cool
okay so our big patty is in there i'm
pretty sure this isn't how popeye's does
it but
i'm pretty happy with this
it's a crust right there
it's kind of funny how much heat this
thing is radiating i can feel it all the
way from here my face is really nice
and warm and this
it's kind of like camping like a
campfire okay so i'm looking for a
pretty good golden brown crust but i
also want the chicken turkey chicken to
cook through i don't know why i keep
saying that but i i
now now we're committed kind of reminds
me of the chicken nugget episode we did
looking pretty good might need to finish
this guy in the oven look at that crust
that's a nice that's a nice crust and we
are coming out
[Music]
that is one patty all right that's one i
have to do another one and this is going
into the oven so we can finish
cooking it through
so it has been
50 minutes almost an hour and it is time
to take my baby out of the oven
oh man that is one this is one smooth
beautiful baby
i hope my baby in the future looks like
looks like this
that's nice okay this bun is done
i'm very proud of this bun
that smells nice
we are now ready to assemble we have a
toasted bun that has been sliced in half
toasted with butter because toasted buns
make a world of a difference three big
turkey chicken turkey patties culinary
team was gracious enough to help me make
two while i was uh manhandling this
first one over here we have pickles
spicy mayo that we did make earlier i
think ain't nothing to it but just to
just do it according to google images uh
the popeye's chicken sandwich does start
off with the layer of the mayo i'm gonna
get that on here
yeah some nice sauce
nice asmr
and now
the chicken we gotta get you over there
this is awesome
[Music]
one
two
oh my god that's what i'd like to see
in three
we got to get the skewer out
come on
[Music]
got it pickles
this might take a minute
this is uh going to be quite fun oh wait
the pickles are supposed to go on the
bottom whatever
i totally forgot i don't like them
better on top don't know why there was
such a craze when this first came out
there were fights over this people were
brawling on them streets and they're
probably fighting over that right now
that chicken's gonna absorb all this
pickle juice real nice all right that
should be good for the pickles now let's
see i'm gonna put on a little bit more
sauce for the top all right top one
yeah
well
that's quite a large uh hop ice chicken
sandwich i want to clean up a bit and
then we're going to finally dig in but
man
i'm excited to eat this
we have one large chicken sandwich and
we have
one large knife there's only one thing
we have to do now oh may the force be
with me
you guys hear that
[Music]
damn
oh my god look at how good this bun is
stuck a pillow
look at this cross section look at these
layers look at this someone tagged
popeyes i will take a little edge piece
little as in the size of a cake this bun
is so good this knife is so good it's
the super slicer and the chicken
is still juicy
as you can see i mean the turkey i mean
the chicken
how does one eat
come on
divide this in two there's like seven
people staring at me right now this is
hilarious
tastes like chicken sandwich from
popeyes i did not expect it to be this
good what the heck i'm gonna keep eating
this for a few minutes
yeah so i ate my piece it was actually
tastier than and closer to the actual
chicken sandwich than i had thought i
think the most exciting thing about this
for me is the bread it's spongy it's
buttery it's delicious it's brioche the
chicken and the turkey the turkey
chicken it's great it's juicy the
pickles are nice the mayo is nice i
could see why people may or may not get
into a physical altercation over this
sandwich hashtag worldstar oh yeah this
was fun i cannot wait to spend the next
couple of days with this sandwich and
that being said thank you for watching
i'll see you guys
next time
[Music]